everyone let me get started here I'm
just pulling up this presentation all
right hello and welcome to today's
session are we have we started recording
yes you'll okay great
hello and welcome to today's session on
bioinformatics for precision oncology
today we're going to be discussing big
data and how it changes our approach to
cancer research as well as translation
to clinical practice we will speak about
the challenges to traditional hypothesis
furch approaches the relationship
between statistical methods and then
machine learning we're also going to go
over several sections in the T bio info
platform which was built for
accommodating both traditional
bioinformatics for processing data as
well as big data mining and machine
learning that is becoming more
commonplace in Big Data studies first
let's go over the course progress and
see how you were getting along with the
online materials we will test how
familiar you are with the process by
asking a few questions regarding the
site navigation
online resources is problem this program
includes and the program structure so it
looks like a few of you have made quite
a bit of progress through the materials
a few of the top performers since we met
earlier in the week are Mikhail and
Elton and I see a lot of you have taken
time to fill out your profiles and
updated with information let's take a
look at one of those so I can show you
some pretty neat features I'm going to
get out of the presentation here for
just a second
I'll just show you my profile here
briefly so note on your profile that you
can see your different groups that
you're available in different mesh
mentions and favorites as well as your
courses that you're involved in and then
within that you can see your quizzes and
assignments and different certificates
and then on your profile you can see
that you can add your name and it would
be really good if you could add your
actual name as opposed to other types of
online handles this just helps us to
identify you and kind of understand
what's going on with stuff also note
that you can add different social media
things so for instance I added my
Instagram and you can see on here a
little bit more about me and this just
kind of helps to build the community
aspect that we're trying to build
obviously later on when you're done with
the courses we would like to feature
your profiles perhaps and so this kind
of allows us to do that
let's review some of the things that we
discussed in our last session starting
from orientation this part of the
session will be prepared presented as a
quiz you can enter your answers into the
zoom chat and if you have questions I'll
address them as they come so where would
you go to find the courses and projects
that are included in this program would
you go to server T - bio info would you
go to the program form the program
syllabus or the course page so the
course is if you want to find out
information about the courses and
projects you could go to the course page
and so I'm going to post the link to
that in chat let's try another one where
do you go with your questions about
course material well the answer to that
is going to meet a program forum and
this one's important to me specifically
because it allows me to go in and kind
of find out which questions you have and
then a lot of times that helps me to
format my upcoming lectures so that we
can go over materials that are more I
guess targeted towards things that you
want to win so the answer that is the
program forum and here's a screen shot
of that
so here's a I guess another photo of the
forum and as you can see here beep sure
has posted the video from last time I'm
Session two your view and I'm gonna also
post a link to that as well and you can
bookmark B's so maybe it might make
things a little bit easier for you to
navigate you can also leave comments and
reviews on each of the courses and this
is also really good for us because it
helps to you know give people better
insights into what's being discussed and
then also please leave a rating and this
also helps us as well
let's try another one so where do you go
to run bioinformatics analysis pipelines
and I know some of you know this one
because some of you are already running
those pipelines do you run
bioinformatics analysis pipelines in
Microsoft Excel or do you log on to
Google Drive or do you log on to zoom no
you know the answer is one server - t
bio info good job Eldon so here's the
photo of the server platform as it is
and there's several different sections
that I want to go over just kind of
reiterate what they are so the first one
is going to be the sections by data type
that being next-generation sequencing
mass spec structural data for others
number two is where you can run analysis
or play around with the demo pipelines I
encourage you to do so just so you can
get a feel for the different sections
number three is where you can learn
about visualization different types of
statistical analysis as well as machine
learning number four if you go to the my
pipeline section you can see the
previous pipelines that you've run as
well as download those files and see
which files you inputted and then
there's number five where you can see
your account information this is also
where you go to law
in so if you ever go in and find out
that you don't have access to something
make sure that you're logged in Elton
has asked if there's a number or a limit
or so if there's a limit on the number
of samples that you can run I think Elia
would probably be good for that question
sorry what's the question again is there
a limit in terms of number of samples
that we can run that the students can
run yeah so the educational licenses
that are included in the program
registration are designed for the
datasets that we already offer in the
materials that are explained for example
in online lessons or the projects
eventually towards the end we will show
you how to leverage some datasets from
the public domain and there you will
have to first submit the project
proposal and there you'll describe how
many samples you are planning to analyze
but when you purchase a research
licensed after you've learned how to use
the platform there's no limitation as to
how many samples you run there's a
limitation of space and you get 5
terabytes of space which you know
typically is enough for many samples but
it also depends on what you do with
those samples how many pipelines you run
so it's a little bit of a tricky
question the simple answer is right now
you are limited more by the type of
project rather than how many samples so
our next question is where do you go to
see the list of sessions that are
included for the program
you
and the answer for that is this syllabus
sorry about that
they're testing the fire lungs in my
building so I didn't need my microphone
for a second but if you do go to the
syllabus tab on the program page you can
see the different types of lessons that
we're gonna have and kind of be seeing
what we're gonna be doing in the
upcoming sessions so here's a screenshot
of the program syllabus and whenever you
go to the program page you can see that
if you click menu there's a drop-down
and this is where you can access the
syllabus as well as the resources and
then see the members and the faculty
they're involved and so that's right
there alright so last time we met Elia
started to speak to you about cancer
biology at the cellular and tissue
levels you learned about the rules of
DNA changes and gene expression
variation that's related to cancer risk
progression and the outcomes let's
revisit some of those concepts and make
sure that those are clear as we move
forward so a doctor can detect cancer
once clinic once clinical signs are
evident from available data these
available data are going to be patient
scans x-rays or different types of blood
tests once they're detected a tumor is
going to be evaluated for malignancy the
criteria for malignancy includes
increased cell proliferation the loss of
the differentiation some type of
infiltrative growth or metastases to
other organs if the tumor that is
performed from these cells has been is
still contained within the tissue of the
organ and it's going to called an into
Institute cancer this type of cancer may
remain contained indefinitely if some
cells experience additional mutations
that allow the tumor to invade
neighboring tissues and shed cells into
the blood or limb the tumor is said to
be malignant
so it's malignant whenever it goes to a
different
at the tissue it's called in situ
whenever it's in the same type of tissue
malignant or escaped cells will
establish or they may establish new
tumors which are called metastases at
other locations in the body and the
development of cancer cells is a process
of deregulation of key molecular
mechanisms cancer is a complex condition
that's manifested in changes in cell
regulation at many different levels this
results in an abnormal growth that we
observe as what are called tumors tumors
consists of cells whose growth and
morphological characteristics are
markedly different from those of normal
cells a malignant a malignant tumor
develops across time and develops
molecular changes as a result of DNA
mutations these types of mutations
affect signaling pathways which can be
measured by changes in gene expression
so therefore cancer is a disease of
molecules and genes and we even know how
many of the molecules and genes are
involved these changes occur in cancer
cells as well as its surrounding tissues
and this is called the micro environment
this micro environment includes many
different kinds of cells which include
immune cells and cancer cells that learn
to evade and even assist in processing
the different types of things that occur
in Terry development so let's go through
some things just to help you understand
I apologize they're testing the firearms
here so to remember these aspects of
cancer biology there are different
hallmark features that were identified
these are distinctive and complimentary
capabilities that enable tumor growth as
well as metastatic dissemination these
have evolved over the past decade and
they now include sustaining
proliferative signaling evading growth
suppressors the activation and invasion
of metastases enabling repla to give a
more immortality as well as inducing
angiogenesis of energetic pathways and
then resisting cell death there are an
additional four which would be
deregulating cellular bioenergetics
avoiding immune destruction and then
tumor promoting inflammation the last
time we spoke about one of the most
fundamental traits of cancer cells which
involves their ability to sustain
chronic proliferation
ja if you would like me to take ya Elia
if you don't mind can you take over to
have me
stop sharing your screen okay sorry
everyone for this change cheer we're
going to just quickly change screens I'm
gonna share my screen okay if you can
hear or if you can see my screen here
we're going to go through this you know
these hallmarks of cancer and as Joe
started mentioning this also has been
evolving over time so what you see here
on the screen are the six hallmark
features of cancer that were originally
established and those are sustaining
proliferate of signaling evading growth
suppressors activation invasion and
metastasis enabling replicative
immortality inducing angiogenesis
energetics and resisting cell death so
those are the traditionally kind of
considered hallmarks of cancer in the
recent decade additional four have been
added so there's a total of 10 and the
additional four are deregulating
cellular energetics avoiding immune
destruction tumor promoting inflammation
genome instability and munication so
let's talk about these in detail last
time we spoke about the most fundamental
traits of cancerous cells that involves
their ability to sustain chronic
proliferation right so this one right
here is sustaining proliferate of
signaling and that is what drives tumor
progression right so we talked how a
normal kid cell becomes a cancerous
tumor is this sustained proliferate of
signaling normal tissues carefully
controlled the production and release of
growth promoting signals that instruct
entry into and progression through the
cell growth
division cycle thereby ensuring a
homeostasis of cell number and thus me
maintenance of normal tissue
architecture and function cancer cells
by deregulating these signals become
masters of their own destinies
the enabling signals are conveyed in
large part by growth factors that bind
cells surface receptors typically
containing intracellular tyrosine kinase
domains the latter proceed to emit
signals we have ranged intracellular
signaling pathways that regulate
progression through the cell cycle as
well as cell growth so they increase in
cell size and they divide more often
these signals influence yet another cell
biological properties such as cell
survival in an energy metabolism evading
growth suppressors so to prevent this
from happening in normal cells there are
mechanisms to suppress this kind of
growth so cancer cells resist this
inhibitory signal that might otherwise
stop their growth the majority pathways
involved are Auto foggy and death cell
receptor signaling which is known as
apoptosis both of which can ultimately
lead to cell death and reduction in
tumor growth Auto [ __ ] is a dynamic
cellular recycling system that results
in the degradation of cytoplasmic
contents abnormal protein aggregates and
excess or damaged organelles so that the
building blocks or amino acids can be
used to create new cellular components
therefore artifact is a survival
promoting process cancers can up
regulate artifact II to survive micro
environmental stress and to increase
growth and aggressiveness the auto [ __ ]
process involves the formation of an
auto Fagin phagosome which then fuses
with lysosomes to form in an auto [ __ ]
low phago lysosome the process is
regulated by mTOR mpk pi3k and map k
pathways so just remember these names
and remember which process they are
associated with
activating invasion and metastasis
cancer cells invade local tissue and
spread so what you see right here is the
process of metastasis and the process
actually goes through the process of
infiltration of other tissues and so
these are complex processes that
leverage existing cellular mechanisms
such as the adherence junction signaling
pathway to enable invasion and migration
of the tumor cells adherence junctions
are dynamic structures that form
strengthen and spread degrade and then
reform as the their associated proteins
create connections with counterparts
from adjacent cells the adherence
Junction serves multiple functions such
as initiation and stabilization of cell
to cell adhesion regulation of the actin
cytoskeleton intracellular signaling and
transcriptional regulation they can
appear as bands as bands encircling the
cell or as spots of attachment to the
extracellular matrix which are called
adhesion plaques under normal conditions
this helps create order or among the
cells cell to cell junctions linked
cells to adjacent cells in a tissue and
they also regulate tissue homeostasis in
critical cell processes that include
tissue barrier function cell
proliferation migration defects in cell
to cell junctions gave rise to a wide
range of tissue abner abnormalities that
result that disrupt homeostasis and are
common in genetic abnormalities and
cancers enabling replicate of
immortality cancer cells can revert to a
pre differentiated stem like cell
phenotype allowing inhibited cellular
division and other metabolic adaptations
that enable survival in adverse
conditions where there are multiple
signaling pathways involved in these
changes two key components enable
replicate of immortality hippo and WMT
these are multiple pathways involved in
this there are multiple pathways
involved in this characteristic of
cancer cells so
each one of these processes has key
genes and pathways associated with them
you will also see that multiple genes
might have an effect on multiple
pathways and together they form these
hallmarks of cancer inducing
angiogenesis which is what you see right
here
cancer cells stimulate the growth of
blood vessels to supply a nutrients to
tumors angiogenesis is the formation of
new blood vessels from pre-existing
blood vessels this plays an important
role in tumor growth because it brings
the necessary source materials and
energy and also eventually leads to
metastasis because they infiltrate those
and then eventually go through the blood
to other locations in the body resisting
cell death one thing that we know about
cancer cells is that they can resist
death they evade apoptosis the mechanism
that program cell death in one cell
becomes damaged normally apoptosis helps
keep an organism healthy through growth
and development maintaining body tissue
by removing infected or damaged cells
but cancer cells do not follow this
process no matter how abnormally they
grow the cancer cells may alter the
American mechanism that detect the
changes or irregularities preventing
proper signaling and apoptosis
activation for example apoptosis would
be would start once there's a lot of
damage in the DNA right and we know that
the tumor growth and cancer development
is associated with changes in the DNA
but nevertheless they evade the
apoptotic pathway and therefore continue
to replicate with damaged DNA so these
are some of the hallmarks of cancer
again these are the six traditional ones
but today there are more four more that
are acknowledged and some are given more
priority of manatos to study these
processes
we can use next-generation sequencing
data that reveals molecular changes that
lead to deregulation of DNA for example
mutations and also show us how this
process takes place for example changes
in mRNA expression or alternative
splicing we also can detect changes in
regulation of how one goes from the next
so remember that it goes from the coding
sequence in DNA that is forming genes
those genes are transcribed into mRNA
and eventually the mRNA is a product a
functional product a protein and those
proteins can have different changes in
them as a result of the original changes
in the DNA as a result of regulation of
DNA expression or a transcription sorry
and also mRNA alternative splicing and
other post translational modifications
that happen at the protein level so when
we speak about bioinformatics we're
going to be focused on studying the
processes that we went over these
hallmark processes of cancer relying on
data and so to study this data we need
to somehow use the sequences of reads
that are generated in a sequencer
machine and a sequencing machine to
identify changes in DNA find affected
genes and study mRNA transcription
changes using some kind of analytical
methods finally we are also going to be
talking or we talked last time when
we're going to continue talking today
how the data sources are different and
typically used together to drive our
understanding and knowledge about these
processes so we go all the way from cell
lines where we can perform high
throughput experiments on different drug
testing for example or understand the
basic biology of what happens inside the
cell to put those cells in the context
of a real system they are two
we implanted into Endemol models and
those are called patient-derived
xenograft models for example those would
be nice with human tumors implanted in
them and then we also have clinical
trials and different translational
applications of the data and the
information that is being collected we
have prepared a number of projects that
could reveal some of those aspects that
we just talked about so let me briefly
describe what these projects and
datasets
speak about and if you're interested in
any one of these datasets you can let us
know some of them are fully available on
the site some of them are prepared as
internal tutorials that are available in
programs but all of the ones that I'm
showing here are available for you as a
part of this program and you can let us
know if one of those are going to be
interested to you
DCIS chromosomes so you remember the
word in situ which means contained in a
tissue and not spreading beyond that
tissue um there's the difference between
early stage breast cancer and late stage
breast cancer early stage breast cancer
is contained within the tissue and late
stage starts going beyond one single
tissue and spreading to other tissues so
how can we study the differences and
whether we can predict how some early
stage cancer can develop into a
malignant tumor that is dangerous we can
look at DCIS exosomes so exosomes are
particles that contain RNA and DNA and
mRNA as the different pieces of
molecular material that is used by these
cancer cells and we can detect changes
in the DNA in the mRNA in RNA seek and
we can use that and then check whether
the different features that we detect
from exosomes can also help us detect
and separate some more malignant or less
malignant types of breast cancer from
pay
Modelling cancer precision medicine is a
project that we will do a session on
during the program but also it's
available as a standalone project and I
saw actually some of you have been
looking at that already this project is
actually going to focus on RNA seek data
from the original publication but it
will be used to understand molecular
features or expression of genes that can
help us identify subtypes of cancer and
associate those subtypes with efficacy
of different types of treatments from
chemotherapy to traditional chemotherapy
to more targeted sequence targeted
targeted treatments that are being used
in clinical trials changing response in
cancer immune response in cancer Alton
is saying he's interested in tumor
associated macrophages or Tam's
are changing to as a result of tumor
development and so we can study those
different subtypes of these tumor
associated macrophages and understand
how they differ between themselves
because that's actually the tumor
recruiting these macrophages which are a
part of the immune response to instead
of suppress the tumor growth to support
tumor growth and even metastasis so we
can study those molecular changes at the
level of gene expression and that's this
project record here immune response to
changes in cancer we also have a project
patient-derived xenograft models will be
going through this in transcriptomics
one and two two this is a study of the
interaction between the animal models
and the tumor because we are looking at
the micro environment and we would like
to understand the changes in tumors
between different more aggressive or
less aggressive subtypes and the changes
in the micro environment that are may be
specific to those types of molecular
subtypes so Alton we recorded your
interest so will be read
hang out to you with some datasets from
there but you can also find these on the
website and if you need any help beyond
that we'll be happy to assist you with
that okay so sign up great excited so we
will we will review a lot of these
concepts throughout the program in
future sessions as we do the practical
steps of analysis and interpretation a
lot of the datasets from these projects
and publications will be used are there
any questions about what we covered last
time and maybe added a little bit more
information to that from today yes
please
Iftekhar you had some questions please
write them those out in chat or if you
want to unmute yourself and ask those
questions now please go ahead
you
hello yes can you hear me yes yeah
good evening I think it said good
evening actually you have some doubts
the bar because since I'm very new about
this environment is really fascinating
and I'd like to thank their departure
that she has skewed with the last video
as well I have some doubts regarding
this these cruises is payable we had to
pay again or they said no yeah once
you've you've completed the registration
for the program these are going to be
available to you as part of the program
for free ok because I have seen Laura
comics of you know epidemic that you
know makes bioinformatics and all some
courses here so we says that ten dollars
are the per license whether I have to be
for this particular program or it is
altogether free and second question with
relations that it is in online you know
like we are having the online right
course right and we are taking the
classes it will be like the same or it's
kind of videos I have to go through
these you know slides and later on I
have some questions that I can interact
with you please address these problems
thank you very much yes so thank you for
your question as joe is mentioning
before to find the the courses that are
a part of this program you can actually
go to this link
so there's a homepage specifically for
bioinformatics for precision oncology
program this is the link and in this
link now when you get there you see down
here this menu is specific to this
program so if you go right here to
courses those courses are included in
other words you don't have to pay for
them so these are online self-guided
courses what we do is we help monitor
your progress and answer any questions
that you might have where do you post
questions there's a forum right here you
can post any questions and we can
address those questions on the forum or
you can also request a meeting with us
towards the end of the program there
will be a special portion of the program
and dedicated to independent projects
and that's where you can interact with
us and ask any questions and schedule a
meeting one-on-one but for now we will
have these regular sessions like today
twice a week and in those sessions we
will go through some of the material
that we prepared for the program but in
parallel you can go through some of the
material that we have online because a
lot of what we will do in the sessions
is going to supplement and add on to the
material that is presented here online
yeah all right great so thank you for
your question is I knob you have a
question there
did you okay so let me read it out loud
enabling replicative immortality HIPAA
Oh signaling okay so yes we will we will
actually go through some of the pathways
you know you can look right here hippos
signaling pathway right so these are
pathways the things I mentioned before
are different pathways WMT pathway hippo
pathways and I am mentioning these be
we are going to be reviewing how these
different pathways change as a result of
looking at specific project datasets
right so I wanted to establish the fact
that we have genomic elements like a
gene sequence encoded in the DNA then we
talked about how that sequence is
representing some kind of an expressed
protein that has a function but it's
also a part of a pathway of how they are
regulated and what kind of is connected
to what what gene is connected to what
gene so we'll talk a lot about these
different elements of path wastes
functionality sequences and we want to
connect these different things to what
we know to be the drivers and
characteristics of cancer right because
we want to understand the cancer biology
Before we jump into data and sequences
and how to analyze it so that's why I'm
mentioning them now if you want more
information about the specific pathways
you will get the recording of this
session and I will also send you the
slides and you can go through some of
the links that we will mention there and
read some additional papers if you're
interested to specifically focus on
those pathways but I wanted to just if
that is an overview for everyone to kind
of see how these things are related and
beeps if you could make sure that
everybody else is muted for now and if
the car is still unmuted so we don't we
want to have that thank you
okay so are there any other questions
about what we talked talked about today
as a review right before we go on into
the new portion for today
okay if there are no additional
questions let's briefly review we asked
everybody to go through the introduction
to bioinformatics and some of you have
done that I do want to mention that the
first lesson in introduction to
bioinformatics is a survey that we
wanted to use to learn about you and
learn about your interests and so we are
thankful for those of you there have
filled out that already but we do ask
that everybody completes this gives you
a good overview of where bioinformatics
is now and other areas where it's
applied beyond just cancer biology but
also in health care in cancer biology is
a part of that as well
so the course itself is three sections
introduction to Big Data bioinformatics
we'll talk about that today
bioinformatics in healthcare we'll talk
about that today and translational
bioinformatics and we will also talk
about that today and so this material
online really helps prepare you for what
we're talking about today and it's
really short it could be completed in
under two hours of study and again it
also provides us with some information
about you so that we can continue and
adapt our materials to your level and
your background in your experience as
well as your objectives for this course
introduction to bioinformatics has a
quiz at the end and the quizzes actually
help reinforce some of the materials
that we go through to make sure that you
understand the terminology you
understand how to use the information
that is presented there and also as a
result of completing missed material
this information gets updated on your
profile and we would like to help you
get that profile to stand out as much as
possible we have a community of people
like yourself some of them are you know
potential collaborators researchers that
you can collaborate with some of them
potentially might be looking to hire
bioinformatician some of them might want
to be hired right so it's a community we
hope to keep this community dynamic and
so we have a leader board where we
highlight the top achievers from
these online programs that we conduct to
help share about the successes and the
progress that our participants are
making in these programs so encourage
all of you to complete as many materials
as possible as we move on into more
practical hands-on courses and materials
you will also get points for conducting
for running pipelines and conducting
analysis and that is actually where you
can really stand out you also get these
certificates of completion and that is
something that you can post on LinkedIn
and of course use it to demonstrate that
you've completed some of these materials
online so today what we wanted to talk
about is the history and significance of
onyx data and how it is changing what is
happening in oncology so medical data or
simply clinical data is the type of
information that you know have been used
for decades in clinical use temperature
heart rate other data that is on the
surface right so these are disease
symptoms and they are collected in what
we know to be clinical data but this
data is on the surface it is typically
reported as a result of a patient
feeling somewhere now underneath there
are additional levels of regulation that
cause this clinical symptom to appear
and the biomedical data is what is a
combination of both clinical and this
omics data that is underneath the
surface
these include genomics proteomics and
even the microbiome right so today we
know how all of these areas are actually
critical for the overall condition
change from healthy to sick and
especially for tumor progression as we
have learned already so a lot of these
onyx data types are driven by what's
called high throughput sequencing or
also known as next-generation sequencing
so let's talk about
what is this data and how it has evolved
rapidly over the course of the past
several decades recall that it's been
about 70 years since the structure and
function of DNA was discovered 50 years
have been spent since that time
sequencing the human germline genome
which originally took a very long time
and now in after 2015 the 1000 genome
project brought about a significant
number of whole genome sequences to the
research community and in 2018 over
100,000 whole genomes were sequenced
today there is an ever-increasing number
of datasets available that helps that
help researchers understand these sub
cellular processes and translate those
into use by the clinical community the
technologies like next-generation
sequencing are used to explore the roles
relationships and actions of the various
types of molecules that make up the
cells of an organism on the next data
can be generated using next-generation
sequencing and to start learning about
these types of data the opportunities
and challenges they come with we will
talk about how they are used in the
clinical domain now I will talk about
comics in general comics coming from
next-generation sequencing but they
really represent a variety of different
types of data so here you can see
sequences of the DNA which is called
genomics and that typically refers to
changes in the genomic sequence we'll
talk about that more in our next lecture
when we analyze and look for somatic and
germline mutations this also represents
epigenetic data epigenetic data means
changes but that do not come from
changes in the sequence of DNA typically
associated with effects of the
environment we'll also talk about gene
expression data which is the process of
transcription of those gene sequences
into
- mRNA sequences and changes like
alternative splicing the significance of
this data is increasing as we get closer
and closer to translating the
information obtained from research
projects to actual clinical use of
next-generation sequencing data the
weight has been happening over the past
decade is changing the way we can
predict risk identify a prognosis of
disease response to treatment
stratification of patients by molecular
subtypes drug repurposing diagnostics
and even target discovery in fact many
aspects of NGS have already changed both
the understanding of the human genomic
changes for example tumor development or
agents that cause such changes for
example pathogens and viruses it has
also changed the way that we can treat
patients with targeted safer and more
effective treatments so here you can see
some illustrations by Clinical Research
Center's of how they are translating
genomic medicine into practice you can
see here expanded expanded definition of
self right so we can better understand
the germline genome the tumor genome the
microbiome and the different infectious
agents that interfere with some of these
processes we can diagnose conditions
early on hopefully at conception
preconception and even after soon after
birth and also know what the effects of
different changes are going to be as we
grow older earlier disease detection
before clinical manifestation of those
disease symptoms and then we also this
is changing the way that we can do
treatment of disease and prevention so
for example Herceptin is a drug
antibody-based drug that targets the
her2 protein we'll talk about that more
later we will also talk about for
example hepatitis C a major cause of
liver cancer and we'll talk about how
can we detect presence of viruses in the
human cells and how that can affect our
ability to prevent the spread of cancer
for example
and obviously drug safety and really
optimization of that treatments as we
now have additional sources of data that
are non onyx but nevertheless generated
by the patient now at the center of this
process what you can see right here this
is from the Center for cancer research
in Australia you can see in the process
is illustrated by the clinics
interacting with the patients and
sending data to the labs where a central
role of bioinformaticians is to process
and analyze that data that is then
passed on for curation and
interpretation by the tumor board for
example and eventually translated it
into a treatment plan so the role of
bioinformatics is central to the process
of translating a lot of the omics data
information into clinical use and a lot
of that process has been driven by a
reduction in the cost of sequencing of
next-generation sequencing so cheaper
faster and more efficient sequencing
that started with shotgun sequencing
that was introduced during the human
genome project but has significantly
reduced in price very fast from when it
was in 2001
the cost was 100 million to sequence the
whole human genome and then today the
cost of a whole genome sequenced as
sequencing is about just over $1000 now
why
important this price point of $1,000 or
below well because we can compare that
price to some of the other standard
tests that are being done in the clinic
and also we can see how much data how
much information these other tests are
generating so for example x-ray right
it's about 30 megabytes per image if
it's a high-resolution image has a lot
of detail in it and costs about $250 and
it's about 30 megabytes in size computed
tomography which shows for example helps
detect tumors in the brain or inside the
body deeper than what we can see about
800 dollars and you can see between 3
and 50 megabytes and then nuclear
medicine about 636 dollars and about 300
megabytes in size what is the size of a
whole genome in terms of the raw data
that is processed from the whole genome
well the cost is just over $1,000 and
the size is several gigabytes right so
depending on the depth it could be
anywhere between 2 and 10 gigabytes in
size so much larger in terms of data
size for a price that is somewhat
similar right so if we just look at
those two aspects now what's more
interesting even than that is that just
recently just in 2020 this is from the
MIT technology review China's egi said
that it can sequence a whole genome for
just $100 and so watch this video sorry
let's watch this video real quick
the
reason why this can be achieved this
price point can be achieved is because
of this because this is fully automated
right and so that really becomes a
question of automation and high
throughput means that we can generate a
lot of data per single sample and the
process is automated now let's take a
look at what is this next generation
sequencing data the next generation
sequencing technology allows for
Advanced Studies of genomic mutations
gene expression metagenomic data because
it captures a snapshot of targeted
genomic regions whole genomes or the
whole transcriptome whole genome whole
exome or whole transcriptome sequencing
provides a comprehensive view of a
cellular genome the changes associated
with a genome they expressed portion of
that genome for example whole exome
sequencing or provides us with a
detailed view of the transcriptional
profile at a given biological moment
these methods greatly enhance the power
of discovery when we look for changes
associated with conditions like cancer
however to study this data we have to
process the raw reads and turn them into
structured data that is ready for
analysis to understand this process we
need to look at the process of
next-generation sequencing from the
preparation of the sample all the way
until we have a readout of a single read
so what it does and next-generation
sequencing technology captures DNA
sequences generates digital data from
those samples of DNA so first RNA or DNA
is extracted it is shared or broken up
into small pieces
those have adapters attached to them
which is called the library preparation
step when they are applied to a flow
cell
amplified inside the float cell and then
sequenced to detect by synthesis with
reversible terminators to detect which
letter is seen at a given position
inside that short segment so as a result
we have a sequence of C GE T and a
letters nucleotides and we'll talk more
about what those nucleotides are they're
all going to be in cDNA format so these
are gonna be DNA letters and that RNA
and those reads these kinds of segments
can be anywhere between 30 and 300 base
pairs long one major challenge when we
have such easy and increasingly
cost-effective access to data is the
ability to integrate that data to
understand what is happening from a
heterogeneous big data problem right so
it becomes a problem of big data there's
too much data compared to for example
clinical data and extracting information
from that data requires looking at
heterogeneous sources with different
types of information that speak about
the same biological condition that we
would like to investigate so because of
this let us turn now to the big data
challenges and opportunities because big
data is both the problem and an
opportunity and it requires a certain
appreciation of the properties of this
kind of data for us to be effectively
using it to generate meaningful
information now from a biologists
perspective we know that we can observe
specific changes at the phenotype level
and we would like to understand how
those changes are associated with what
we understand to be the molecular
process that results in these
Changez and a lot of times we were we
were trained to look at those
observations to then ask a biological
question to then generate a hypothesis
that hypothesis drives us to create a
controlled experiment where we generate
data and collect that data develop an
analysis that helps us for example prove
or disprove a hypothesis and as a result
we have a report which we call
information right so we go through this
process to arrive at some kind of a
result now typically we think of a
result as a logical connection between
different elements that we can study
right so oftentimes we hope to arrive at
a clear association between different
genies that are combined in two pathways
right so here we have a pathway for
example and we study hallmark
capabilities right so we talked about
these homework aspects or
characteristics of cancer we know that
they are driven by changes in gene
expression what genes well here we can
split those genes into different types
of circuits or pathways that interact
with each other and drive a certain
condition when it comes to big data when
we have ability to study all of the
changes at a given moment in time from a
sample this equation changes essentially
it looks more something like this we
have a lot of different players those
players have complex interactions
between them and it's really a challenge
to reduce everything to the type of a
hypothesis testing experiment that we
typically expect to generate information
so in that is what's called a big data
problem now what makes data big data
first of all there are several V's as
you can see right here that characterize
big data and those are volume four
any value veracity and velocity volume
refers to the amount of data which is
huge for example RNA seek yields
information about pens of thousands of
genes or if we talk about genomic data
we're talking about millions of single
nucleotide mutation variants that are
possible from a given sample variety
this data is unstructured and can be
assembled in many different ways
often times the same phenomenon can be
described in many different ways
depending on the type of sequencer
preparation library preparation
techniques or even handling that effects
what we see as a result of that process
value information that we can extract
from this kind of data is dependent on
many aspects that include noise in the
data technique error rates and
completeness of information a single
sample can contain veracity some samples
have low coverage others have high
coverage but not full sequences others
might be generated by an older sequencer
that had a high error rate even so
including all of this data together can
complete our picture of a specific
phenomenon that we are studying and
finally velocity another important
aspect is the change in data types and
new information that is generated for
example saying your sequencing was
replaced by shotgun sequencing and
eventually now we have an explosion of
single cell sequencing and then we have
new types of sequencing techniques like
Oxford nanopore so we are always
learning new things from these new
additional types of data that are coming
and we have to adapt the way we study
these processes to incorporate these
types of new information that are coming
from these new techniques now the high
throughput sequencing you can see that
it has really significantly grown over
the course of the past 20 to 30 years so
back in 1989 first sequences were
started to be assembled
by NCBI the National Center for
Biotechnology information and the rate
of growth of this data has significantly
risen over the past couple of decades so
you can see also how this has impacted
the ability to translate those logical
schemes that we are used to that are
very logical and easy to understand from
a pathologist or an oncologist or
biologists perspective now even those
people have to deal with this influx of
available data and an information that
is unstructured and changing and
expanding all the time and so as a
result we have to change the way that we
deal with this data from testing a
hypothesis and extracting information to
adapting to the constant flow and
expansion and the complexity of data
that comes out for example the TCGA the
Cancer Genome Atlas has 33 different
tumor types
over 11,000 patients and growing in
seven different data types and you can
see the growth of that data just over
the course of the past decade is
expanding and more and more publications
that are using the data that is
generated to propose new ideas to
propose new characteristics associated
with cancer as a result many researchers
are turning to data mining data mining
is our ability to detect patterns in big
data that has complex that has
complexity so here you can see for
example analysis of different types of
cells and here you can see the patterns
that those cells tab right so these are
complex patterns that are not going to
fit standard statistical approaches for
example of hypothesis testing that
expect certain data distribution and
properties when we talked about
Oh throughput data that low throughput
data was easy to convert to information
so here you can see for example weight
and size Kim two features can clearly
separate men and women right and that is
easy to do by traditional methods of
dealing with this kind of data with this
kind of data that becomes more and more
challenging because the patterns are
complex and we have to rely on data
mining techniques which we will learn
about those include things like
clustering dimensionality reduction but
also require a lot of pre-processing
steps because they work only on
structured data there's also a growing
interest in use of machine learning and
so that's another topic that we will
talk about in the context of this
program machine learning as you see
became more and more increasingly
popular after the human genome was
published after the year 2001 and now it
is in many many publications becoming
more and more commonplace and so the
role of machine learning is really a
result of the growing amount of data
that is available and that is being
generated and therefore we have to also
understand how these machine learning
methods work and what do they really do
to the data when we feed some black box
alright so that is another topic that we
will discuss throughout this program
as a result there's the new process to
dealing and sign up yes we will
definitely give you a brief introduction
to machine learning in fact as you get
through transcriptomics courses and get
to transcriptomics 3 we'll start talking
about we're not gonna jump there right
away but we will have specific sessions
dedicated to machine learning so the
process of that interaction right so
before that I was mentioning how there
is a connection between people
generating the data and people using the
data that goes through a central point
of bioinformaticians that I have to
analyze curate and interpret the data
and that process is becoming more and
more dynamic right we have to speak the
same language for that process to work
but what it actually does is that
someone else right a person at the
clinic a biologist a researcher has to
specify a problem and especially they
have to specify that problem from the
point of view of data what kind of data
are we going to generate what is that
experiment going to generate how are we
going to extract the answer to the
problem from the data that is being
generated can we find that data from
previous experiments that were already
conducted or from publicly available
data that is already out there that's
why we have to build analytical tools
and environments that integrate data
bases of available experimental design
oftentimes we generate some kind of a
model based on that data the model could
be simulated the model could be
predictive but that model essentially
helps us analyze and visualize data in
such a way that we can make decisions
and interpret the results and so this
iterative process is what you will see
more and more as the role of a bound
from attrition to facilitate the
discovery and the translation of
information found in these complex data
sets to a practical use either in
discovery in research and basic research
translational research or in
the clinic in real life it might look
like an integration of these different
aspects of cancer biology that could be
studied on animal models on patients and
on single cell lines or just sellings so
this problem of big data is really
changing the role of bioinformatics it's
also changing the way that other people
that traditionally have not had to rely
on bioinformatics have to now utilize
bioinformatics in every area of their
research or even clinical practice so
just as an example I wanted to highlight
for example the evolution of breast
cancer classification that we will be
talking about very soon the evolution of
breast cancer classification right we
talked about the hallmarks of cancer but
those hallmarks are just general
attributes characteristics and today
when we apply these different
characteristics to study what happens in
the real world what happens in real
patients we have to understand how the
molecular data is changing our ability
to separate those different cancers into
groups into different defined molecular
subtypes we will also talk about how we
can integrate the different data types
and what they allow us to see to study a
variety of things that we cannot expect
from patients like for example this
project on efficacy of drugs which
obviously is not going to be possible if
we just have access to patient data any
questions on what we had for today's
session
you
these couple of first sessions are
really introductory to get everybody on
the same page and so that's why we spent
some time last time and today to speak
about the learning environment and the
process that we will follow as these
programs develop and become more more
practical so I wanted to make sure that
everybody is familiar with a little bit
of cancer biology and a little bit of
the problems associated with
next-generation sequencing and Big Data
before we jump into the practical parts
of the projects and the analysis now a
great question from iftikhar how to get
the NGS data and to understand or
interpret it so we will we will first of
all provide you with some examples to
get started with in fact yes in fact
next session is going to be dedicated to
identification of DNA variants so single
nucleotide variants based on analysis of
genomic and exams seek data where we
will talk about germline and somatic
mutations and what are some of the
practical steps like mapping and
detection of variants and comparing
between the normal and the tumor data
and will actually use the real data set
and then how do we actually interpret
that kind of information right so what
are the file types how do we interpret
those files how to visualize that data
and things like that
we'll do that next time when we meet on
March 16th and after that we will also
talk about our Nasik how can we study
gene expression and eventually we'll
learn how this data can inform us about
these different molecular processes that
we started talking about that define
cancer biology
okay are there any other questions Darko
q for additional information yes
get the data
we will have a session on how let me
actually go through there a lot of
questions about some of the things that
we actually plan to to go through in
this program so let me kind of describe
what will be covered so that we can stay
focused so there are other you know
repositories for the different for the
different things that we will do but if
you go right here under syllabus you can
see what are the different topics that
will be covered so we already did
introduction to oncology where we talked
about cancer biology challenges we
talked today about big data
bioinformatics and some of the things
that we have to think about next time
when we meet we will talk about DNA
variants and mutations and so how to
analyze genomics data then we'll talk
about next generation sequencing
transcriptomics for RNA seek data we'll
talk about statistical methods of
analysis that are used for analysis of
RNA seek process data tables of
expression we'll talk about
interpretation using gene ontology is
functional and gene set enrichment
analysis based on pathways then we will
actually get to where to find data and
how can we use some examples from cell
line data and from animal models and
that is data found on NCBI which is the
National Center for Biotechnology
information you can find a lot of
different information there so please
visit the link that Mohit gave that
explains where we can find RNA seek data
on cancer then we'll talk about TCGA the
Cancer Genome Atlas where we can find
data from patients and there you'll find
data such as clinical data
I'm not sure you can get MRI or x-ray or
something like that from patients
without being approved first but you
know you can go through the approval
process we'll also talk about different
databases of mutations like NCI and
cosmic then we'll start talking about
projects right so our goal in this
program is to prepare you for
independent analysis of these kinds of
data so that you can actually think
about how to apply the techniques that
you've learned about to real projects
right and we'll not only talk about
where to find the specific data set but
we'll also talk about how to select that
data set and how to propose an idea that
is valuable and competitive so that your
inquiry and translational value of the
analysis is going to be solid for
example how many samples to include and
reproducible so how do you record all of
the steps that you do so that others can
arrive at the same conclusions as you do
and then we'll spend some time going
through project examples how to do
classification of subtypes and breast
cancer how to deal with different cell
lines and then we'll also include liver
cancer from TCGA and analysis of the
different factors that we have I believe
yeah this is just problems with the
image so that's what we plan on to cover
and I hope that you can join us for
every one of these sessions and if not
the recordings are going to be available
so you can already see the recording of
the previous session that was posted
right here on the forum if you want to
find any of the previous recordings
please make sure to go there there's
going to be a post from beach' where we
have session recordings and so you'll
see here the different recorded sessions
with links to YouTube all right so great
thank you everyone for joining today we
ran a little bit over time but hopefully
you enjoyed the session
and will be looking forward to seeing
you again on May 16th
next time
Thank You darker when Joe and Mohit and
beep shop for joining today also
okay what do we need to prepare for next
week again if you have not finished
introduction to bioinformatics please
complete that most importantly complete
the surveys that are included there and
start going through the introduction to
genomics and genomics one depending on
how much you can achieve before now in
next time those are the two next courses
that we are going to be discussing
genomic data alright have a great rest
of the day take